[Music]
hey welcome to hannity all right we're
going to change format a little tonight
buckle up far left new york city mayor i
affectionately call him camara de blasio
2020
democratic hopeful well bill de plazio
to his credit he sat down with me for an
exclusive one-on-one interview
so far he's the only 2020 democrat brave
enough
to come on this program and we commend
him for that
we covered a wide range of issues went
much longer than we thought
obamacare socialism new green deal
police officers no topic was
off the table immigration abortion
second amendment we got them all in
so without further ado buckle up the
media
you're gonna love this part one
do you support walls on our border
i support border security but not walls
no walls i don't think we need
additional walls because look there's 11
million people here right now sean this
is more
maybe but this is why i don't get about
the whole discussion bluntly on this
network and a lot of other places
11 million people here they've been here
for decades this is the biggest don't
ask don't tell in american history
why are we allowing ourselves to be
divided by as a people when in fact this
already happened okay how are you
all right there's no invasion there's
many people here already are a part of
our community
90 of the heroine that comes into this
country crosses the southern border
fentanyl a big percentage crosses the
southern border we're losing 300 people
a week
you know all about the opioid epidemic
in a big city like we fight it every day
i have to we have to save these kids and
so my question is between i think the 99
of people that want to come here want
what we have and i don't blame them
there is one percent though two year
period there were 4
000 homicides 30 000 sexual assaults a
hundred thousand violent assaults by
illegal
immigrant criminals the one percent i
wanna be very clear
my question to you is very simple if you
don't have the wall
how are you gonna stop them people get
in with a wall without a wall that's not
how you do it what you do
is you create an actual border security
mechanism you have
every tool you need and you create a
reality in
our communities all the way across the
border
in our communities where police and
community are working together in this
city
we have 170 crimes that if someone's
convicted of them they're undocumented
they're out of here okay and we work
with communities to make sure
we find people who have done things
inappropriately you sort of
have have a sanctuary city and those of
you i don't
accept any of these terms i want to talk
about here's the facts
bill de blasio has nearly 500 000
illegal
uh immigrants in his city those are the
facts those are the census facts and you
said
you want the new york taxpayers to pay
for their health care
sean right now this is another charade
and you have to decide how honest you
want to be
so where do people get that is that not
true no where did they get their
healthcare
did you not say that wait i mean
dishonestly are there 500 thousand five
hundred thousand people do you want free
health care for everyone
every new yorker i'm answering a
question legally new yorker
everybody who's here illegal or to get
legal health care because what's
happening right now
folks go to the emergency room because
they don't have a doctor and who's
paying for it the same taxpayers
so the taxpayers it's a simple question
the answer is yes you support
new york city why not have an honest
conversation
with reality just to be clear
500 000 illegal immigrants in new york
city should get free health care
that's what you just said everybody who
lives here
should get the health care they need so
that everyone can be healthy not get
each other sick
even if they're illegal even if they're
undocumented i'll tell you why
because otherwise what's happening
people go to the emergency room the
taxpayers pay anyway
people get sicker so these are human
beings who are part of our economy who
are part of our neighborhood
right every neighborhood in this city
there's not a sign that says who's
undocumented i got your answer i
understand
i want to know whoa two-way street so do
you agree
that people go to the emergency room
when they're sick i think that we should
and we end up paying for it anyway if
you want to change the laws my answer is
i believe we should no nation we are a
constitutional republic i
revere our constitution i revere the
rule of law
and i understand i think why 99 percent
of people want to be here because
they want what we all take for granted
that god has given us
and i want to have a wall
to stop the heroin let me finish stop
the cartels
but you're not answering michael i am
answering your question i want the
criminal elements to be vetted and i
want a big door that says
welcome to our family welcome to our
country and you want
comprehensive immigration reform well
i'm telling you no but do you want
comprehensive immigration reform cause
i've got 11
my answer is absolutely we only we give
those
highly coveted slots to the people that
respect our lives john this is why it's
such a charade
you've got eleven it is a charade stop
it you are doing and what your network
does too often it tries to distract
my network by the way there are people
on my network that don't
like a single word i say what are you
talking about monolithic
i agree you're not a monolith but too
much of the time what fox and news corp
do is try and take people's
minds off of the fact that they're being
screwed economically by the one person
we're going to get to that
no but you're not answering no but i
promise after the lightning round which
isn't really lightning we're going to
get back to that
you're honestly going to tell me why
it's okay that the one percent are
paying less and less in taxes now that
we're back to the late round i want to
ask you a new question and we're going
to
wait are you promising me you're going
to raise that question we're going to
get back to immigration we're going to
get back to taxes i promise you
uh-huh okay you're watching probably be
watching you're sitting right here
you're watching yourself you're watching
the monitor right there you can watch
yourself i'm watching
all right you came and
with some of new york's finest
if you go to work every day like the
people that are with you to protect you
which i
fully support because there's dangerous
times
and they are our police officers and
they're armed
and we have a big debate because there
are
i've been a responsible gun owner my
entire life
somebody calls my radio show and says
what kind of gun should i get showing
i'm like which gun do you want to get
trained in the use of
and what safety courses are you going to
take so serious my mom was a prison
guard on long island
and for 25 years 16 hour shifts every
day god bless her and she had a loaded
gun next to her bed and she made sure
that dopey 10 year old kid me
knew how to handle a firearm so my
question is
you have that hollywood stars can afford
armed guards should every new yorker
should every american have the ability
if god forbid the criminal element
invades their home invades their
property
to have a gun in their home to protect
themselves
okay like you do you're in the safest
big city in america
and ask you that i'm i'm prefacing i you
preface all the time
safest big city in america finest police
force in america we keep people safe
crime's gone down six years in a row on
my watch i believe
right that's true this is true thank you
i believe right now what's wrong in this
country
is not that people have rights around
guns
it's that there are no gun safety
measures like background checks like
we do have background checks i don't buy
a gun without getting a background check
we don't have sufficient background
checks
i have a gun carry license in new york
you i have to walk
over hot coals to get about the whole
country by the way
ask the nypd and they'll tell you they
believe in strong gun laws
to keep losers and civilians safe my
question is simple
does every new yorker if they're
mentally stable
if if they have the background check and
they don't have a criminal background or
mental
illness problem do average people should
they have the same
safety you have and if somebody breaks
into their house
can do would you would you respect their
right to have a firearm in their house
everyone deserves to be safe
and asking the answer is not for
everyone to have a firearm any more than
it's for every team
i believe people have rights but i also
believe we need background checks we
need an assault weapon ban
if you have a waiting period for
purchase okay because right now what's
happening and every american have a
shotgun in their house every new yorker
you're not answering about your dodge
jeans they're not dodging all the guns
that are out there
that are threatening our officers and
civilians alike should every new yorker
have the same protection you have people
have rights
i believe we need new gun safety i
believe people have brand should they
have the right to a gun
we have a police department and i've
added 2 000 officers on patrol in this
city in the last few years
great that is making it safer all the
time should the best way to protect
should
every new yorker that has a perfect
mental health
hold on have a perfect mental health
record and have a background check
would you agree that they have a right
everybody's safe
do you agree they have a right to have a
gun in their house right to be safe
great do they have a right to a gun i'm
telling you what i think yes or no i've
answered you the
safest way to do it you're not answering
a police department
that is supported by the time you call
the cops even if it's a great response
time you might be dead
again we just have a different you're
protected
you have a you have a team around you
does every new yorker if somebody
breaks into their house they're good
people the law-abiding people pay their
taxes obey the rules
pass the background check should they
have a right to a gun in their house
yes or no i ain't buying what you're
selling you're not but so the answer is
no but you're afraid to say
answer is my answer you don't get to
tell other people what their answer is
should everyone have the right to a gun
in their question here is how do we make
people safe
it is yes it is that was one question i
would have asked you to get
guns out of this society they're
everywhere they can't be everywhere
they're threatening our officers the
answer to your question is
new yorkers that have perfect mental
health records
and willing to go through background
checks should not be allowed to have a
gun in their home i just don't play by
your rules
should they be allowed to do this with
everyone let people define themselves
you want to hear the truth when they
have a gun is a simple question if
they're law abiding
can they have a gun you are trying to
set up a reality
where you get to paint a picture on your
own terms it doesn't work that way mr
mayor
those guys over there what did i say to
you guys i said thank you for what you
do
every day they protect you you deserve
to be protected you're the mayor of the
biggest city and everyone deserves taxes
for the biggest one
everyone deserves to be protected and
that's what we're doing here but they
can't have a gun
that's what we're doing can't have a gun
again ask
law enforcement if they want everyone to
have a gun that is not the way to keep
everyone safe
listen i i appreciate you being here but
that is a simple question and you are
dodging and ducking
you're flipping what i believe all right
that's fair enough you say it's in the
wrong hands what i think okay
so here's sean hannity that's been
financially independent since he's 10.
you know all the jobs i've done i heard
it but 25 years do you think my current
system is fair
do you think that my money that i've
earned and saved
is in the wrong hands i think that's
a yes or no do you think the money i've
made is in the wrong hands listen to
what i'm saying
you think right now your viewers feel
that it's okay that the wealthy have as
much as they have and pay as little in
taxes
you think it's okay that big
corporations pay nothing in taxes you
know how much i made you think that's
okay no corporations pass taxes on to
people corporations no but there are
there are corporations that pay no taxes
in america listen
amazon's won all i know all i know is
this
i've always known in my career and we
learned it with lois lerner
that i better damn well pay my taxes
because if i don't
i have no doubt that obama biden would
have got
read every tax year here's what i will
say the kid that started out with no
money
and started in radio fork for free
and made 19 000 a year and i left my
home in new york and i went five years
rhode island five years california two
years alabama four years georgia and i
got lucky
and i got hired here and i'm asking you
still want 70 cents of every dollar i
have
and then you want more if i save too
much and then you want more when i drop
dead
and i think you're stealing from me i
want working-class people and
middle-class people have a better life
so i deserve that money because you say
it's in the wrong hands is that my money
this is my general view of the world you
got there with the help of very friendly
government policies
not taking away your work i'm not taking
away your work
but the rich have gotten richer for 40
years and paid less and less in taxes
corporations of america paying nothing
in taxes
that's not america that's not america
where the chosen foreign
corporations when they when you raise
their taxes what do you think
they do i think the problem with your
whole line here is that you seem to
think the status quo is okay
i don't raise taxes i don't think your
viewers think the status quo is okay
what do you think corporations do when
government like you raises their taxes
they have to pay their fair share no
they pass the costs on to the consumers
they have corporations don't pay taxes
you're right
they pass those costs on to us do you
think it's okay you think it's okay
they're ceos making three hundred four
hundred times listen let me tell you the
workers in their companies are paying
you talking to the wrong guy i'm the
blue collar guy
that worked 25 years ago i'm saying do
you think it's okay they're ceos in
america you know what i'm most happy
about
200 400 times what an average worker in
a company's market i am so happy you
think that's okay
that i gave you the numbers under biden
obama and i gave you the numbers under
trump
the new york mets had ray sadecki tom
seaver jerry kuzma no i guess duffy dyer
jerry
brody
we've never had you did that's cool by
the way i gave the keys to the city to
the 69
who are still with us god bless them
including crane pull still with us and
bud house
and buddy still with us god i gave each
of them a key
by the way when do i get my key to the
city so but when if you if you join the
mets
[Laughter]
oh if i live in this if you join the
mets you might have a chance but
the look the bottom line is i don't hear
you saying you shouldn't
thank donald you know why because listen
i
i believe in god i believe god created
every man woman and child on this earth
with all my heart
i need to be a better christian but i
want to be a christian
and i really believe that and the fact
that we have the best employment
situation since
1969 the best the lowest unemployment
record low unemployment campaign about
people
african-americans asians are those
numbers what about what's happening
numbers
those are jobs those are people's jobs
what has happened for decades before
that this is what you don't answer i
mean listening for an answer i gave you
the
obama years from reagan till now the
rich have gotten consistently richer
paying less and less
taxes to this no because 40 years is a
long time
and we have got to break out of it can
you know when the good old days were
we know when the good old days were
eisenhower and kennedy
when the wealthy paid taxes at the level
i'm proposing
wealth was better shared there was more
investment business
and listen i run i run a huge huge talk
about government
business excuse me 380
000 employees i have a budget
non-government did you ever run a
private business
but i'm asking you you don't seem to
want to answer the question
do you believe that in the last 40 years
working class and middle class people
have not moved forward you know
i think if you ask me they would tell
you they have my grandparents came to
ellis island
that's the point that's the point the
american dream they had we don't have
right now
they came here with on average 10 bucks
in their pocket all four of my
grandparents
my father grew up poor in bed stuy
wasn't a good place at the time my mom
grew up in the south bronx
they had nothing growing up absolutely
nothing
my father fights from world war ii and
as did my dad
and yeah and he got a 50 by 100 lot long
island
13 000 house that was success the answer
to your question is
yes we can all do better but we don't
government's not the answer mr mayor who
said that
money is you talk a lot about money
being in the wrong absolutely wait a
minute
are you saying the people that have
money stole it can i tell you exact
quote
let's be fair money or i said there's
plenty of money in this world
there's plenty of money in this country
it's just in the wrong hands
how did it get working because of
federal policies that took from
working people and gave it to the one
person okay so you want to wealthy
i want working people get their fair
share i mean okay let me so should
anyone be working for less than 15
an hour so let's go i don't i don't like
the minimum wage because you don't think
people you worked
you described your life as a working man
i respect that you don't wash dishes
people should get i was 15 an hour in
today's economy
no i because no because it hurts the
kids that get jobs we now have record
low unemployment youth unemployment and
if i didn't work as well that would be
talk about people trying to support
their family
you don't think folks who are working
hard to get fifteen dollars minimum mr
mayor let me come back let me go over
the numbers that matter that's what the
labor movement fought for
something decent you said the following
the money's in the wrong hands and you
want to
tax the hell out of people i do want to
and people should go to tax2health.com
they can get all the information about
my tax plan which is the most aggressive
i have it i want to go over with you
please do so the top 1 pay
30 of the taxes the top 20 the bottom
fifty percent of american
wage earners pay one percent
federal income tax fifty percent pays
one
and the other fifty percent the rich who
you wanna take more from
they pay it all so my question is so
i in your city of new york let's go over
new york for example
all right at the top marginal rate i
don't get the deduction any longer
because of the president's tax deal i
think that was a mistake i pay higher
taxes
but the president was wrong to take away
state and local deductions you want me
to pay more so he's making you pay more
it was wrong to take it away and by the
way middle-class people working-class
people
paid for that question by your friend
the president what should the federal
tax rate be
for individuals 70 percent for folks who
make over two million dollars in seventy
percent
seventy percent that means when you
combine everything that means they get
to keep thirty percent
yeah okay you take 70 cents out of every
dollar
again how long do we have this country
for decades white eisenhower
john f kennedy tax rate then 70 cents on
every dollar
corporations what should they pay what
is the top marginal rate for
corporations that you want
i think right now is way too low i would
like to give me a number give me a wall
park
a ballpark between 40 and 50 okay no
business is going to want to be in
business and they'll pass the cost on
the consumers and they'll lose jobs
here's what we have
wait a minute whoa i want you to know
what i pay in new york okay
because i pay the nine percent state tax
i pay the city tax you have me have four
percent you know in new york
my income goes to you um and i don't
even live here
i don't live in the city by the way just
saying you make a good income here okay
new york city has an extra 4.875 sales
tax on top of that
then if people out of the 30 percent
you're going to let them keep
you want to then come back later and say
well if you saved
millions i want 1 percent more
2 percent more 3 percent more you want
another
bite of the apple after they paid your
70 cents on the dollar and one more
thing
and then if you drop dead then new york
gets another 16.
what about the and the federal
government what about all the working
people who created all the wealth
the guy who owns the factory the guy who
owns the company did not create the
wealth the people who did the work
created why do you
feel they are not getting their fair
share
[Music]
so for weeks we've shown you these
alarming videos of new york city police
officers being assaulted and doused with
unknown liquids some have accused the
mayor of preventing new york city's
finest from adequately responding
or even making an arrest so what is the
mayor doing to combat this shocking new
trend part two of my interview
i mentioned the guys that you came in
this building with um
i honor them they to me are my heroes
that's my family my extended family you
know almost
you can check it out i applied to be a
new york city police officer
and i got a 99 on the test i even passed
the psychological
and then the physical i was going to do
the standards were lower back then
you're such a jackass that was a jackass
comic book was very good
um but here's the point i love these
guys
we see them doused with water
we see these guys now those are felony
assaults against
our bravest and those folks are being
arrested who did that
all right so i want this promise from
you and i hope will agree on this
i want every video gone over with a
fine-tooth comb and every one of those
people
that assaulted your officers our
officers
that put a gun on because their jobs are
dangerous every day
that protect and serve i want to promise
from you
that you're going to identify every one
of those people that attack those guys
that's what we do
that is what that hasn't happened oh
come on you haven't arrested every one
of them by us
rich how many benefits they've been
identified and arrested consistently
the nypd does its job how many have been
arrested wait wait wait wait are you
saying they might look at the videos
look at these videos
i'm asking a question the end are you
saying nypd is not doing their job well
let me give you
some news i am saying that those
statements are better than that they
deserve the very best and we are
arresting each and every one of you
who did any assaults you can look right
here i want you to look you are you're
amazing wait wait wait wait
every single guy every single face we
see will you arrest them
sean anybody the nypd deems to commit a
crime will be arrested
everything listen i want to say respect
the professionalism no
respect the professionalism the nypd
that they are going to follow the law
and go after anyone
that did why do you make this so hard
because you're playing a game
i'm not playing against this is a
serious thing no mister look that's
serious i'm serious as a heart attack i
do not think the nypd knows how to do
his job because i know they know here's
my question is the mayor of new york
city i just
want to ask you a question do they know
how to do their job again
when i run for president i just don't
hear you answering right uh here's what
i'm going to tell you
they know how to do their job all right
they know how to do their job
they've brought down crime consistently
with the safest big city america i give
you credit
why don't you murder respect the fact
that these guys know what they're doing
and they're going to bring everyone to
justice okay
because i know that you made you i know
that but here's my question for you
every person on video that is everyone
has committed a crime
every single everyone who's coming
will you promise this is incredible you
yes that's not a good enough statement
for you that everyone who commits a
crime will be brought to justice that's
america
is everyone in there is everyone in that
video leave our professionals who are
police officers
know who commits a crime and they will
bring this is that video evidence to you
over assault
why do you not respect the nypd enough
to believe they can know that that's a
silly statement we're an ipd hat and
shirt every day so then why don't you
respect them to do their job
is that a crime that would happen yes or
no sean you either respect them they
don't don't play a game here no games
the nypd will arrest them and they know
what they're doing and you promised to
try to arrest everyone
of course anyone who commits a crime of
any kind we're going to arrest
hallelujah i've got to go to prison no
but you're playing the game man stop no
no that's not a game
you are playing that's not a game
because you have to acknowledge this is
the finest police force in the nation
that continues to happen they don't
you had a low military rate in the last
three years great i'm happy i give you
credit
listen all credit unto me i give the
credit to the nypd
and i put 2000 more officers on patrol
and this
is an extraordinary police force that is
getting better all the time and working
more and more closely with communities
and that's going to take us forward but
this stuff you're talking about that's a
smoke screen
they know how to do their jobs as long
as they know how to do their jobs
mr mayor this is not a game to me as
long as they're all arrested it's a game
if you think they don't know how to do
their job slow down
why do you think they wouldn't arrest as
long as they're as long as they're all
arrested i'm going to be a happy host
listen respect that show and interview
me listen
to this respect the fact that in this
city we didn't become the safest big
city in america by accident
we did it by investing in our police
rudy giuliani
i you know what david dinkins rudy
giuliani david yes he did
i like david personally he got stopped
he got the cops first from albany the
money for the cops he did
it's fact okay and then rudy implemented
bloomberg racist
and then bloomberg and then me but
here's the thing six years in a row
crime goes down
we've improved the relationship between
police and community we've done things
that have not been done before but have
bonded police and community together
we've retrained the entire police force
yeah and we've added two thousand more
officers on patrol those are the facts
i'm going to say this i'm never going to
agree with you you drive me crazy and
you don't answer questions
you know you duck a lot but thank you
for coming in
and i take very seriously
those men and women that's my family
this is our city
i want every person in the city
protected i want you protected
by the way you should rethink every
single
new yorker should have the means to
protect themselves with a weapon
because you have a they have the finest
police forces in america security
they have the finest police force in
america we're going to keep making it
stronger and stronger all right you're
not going to raise my taxes
oh great i'm going to have to pay more
taxes if you could become president
so kids can have pre-k you want to steal
my money you can tell me kids can have
preachers generously
anyway i don't need it
all right so we covered a lot of ground
with mayor de blasio right back to our
interview where i asked the mayor to
explain his party's extreme abortion
agenda whether
he thinks there should be any
restrictions on the procedure at all
pretty simple question does he answer it
take a look
[Music]
okay now we have a lot of controversial
issues do you support
any restrictions on abortion look
that's a simple question it's a simple
answer i believe in roe v wade i believe
the decisions between a woman and her
doctor
right but but where it's gotten
controversial is for example in virginia
when you have a bill proposed that would
allow
during birth dilation abortions and a
governor of virginia that said
well first we're going to
uh birth the baby make the baby
comfortable hang on
then we'll let the mother decide do you
support
any restrictions on abortion no that's a
simple question
it's a simple answer i would steve and
roe v wade and detroit
will send it back to the states again
what you're going to do and i respect
that this is your job
i have a job to do too your job is to
try and make this sometimes a cartoon
and i'm trying to tell you what this is
about a woman's right to choose which is
under
okay i have many pro i have many i live
in new york i have many friends that are
democrats
and and consider themselves pro-choice
but
for example do you think a woman in the
ninth month
putting aside health putting aside life
of the mother
do you support any restrictions until
the baby's born that's a simple
question no i believe it's a smoke
screen because it doesn't happen in
america
women make this choice it's a sacred
choice there are now
ten states that are debating whether or
not you could have a
sacred choice for women can that are
allowing people to have an abortion
up until the moment of birth do you
support that listen
here's the problem with this whole
discussion you won't answer women no
the problem is that women make this
choice it's a very difficult choice it's
a very personal choice
and what we need to respect is that's
not a choice any woman wants to make
okay overwhelmingly
americans believe in protecting the
rights you want to be president
eight months into a pregnancy tell you
what i believe i'm here and i'm not i
don't understand here's my
simple question eight months into
pregnancy should a woman be allowed
legally to have an abortion
again i've told you i believe a woman's
right to choose period this is a smoking
strategy yeah it's a smokescreen no i'm
not answering your way i'm answering my
way
let's move on i want to i want to ask
you
the degree new deal here
let's go through the yes or no's first
and then i'll let you expand on it i
know what you've said about buildings
we're not going to build it with
glass and we're not going to build them
with uh what do you call it um
glass and steel steel there you go okay
i worked i do this for a living i say
um and so i told you a little bit about
my background
got a little talk before the before we
came on air
that's 20 some odd years of my life blue
collar my dad worked for the city of new
york he's a
family corporation guy my mom was a
prison guard all my family were new york
city cops only two were fbi guys
and i was the lost sheep of the family
and
as as i look at that i think of okay
if you're going to tax the hell out of
people that want to build with glass and
steel
and you're going to put the restrictions
on it my mind goes to my friends
i have friends that are cops firemen
steel workers
plumbers electricians are you concerned
about people having jobs no what am i
concerned about if you
your plan will prevent tall buildings
from being built in the city
at all but it's going to cost more
according to your own words
it's very clear sean you want to build a
skyscraper you've got to build a
skyscraper
we want we want people look look all
over new york city sign the dotted line
there you go all over new york city you
see cranes you see construction
workers you see a lot of employment i
believe in that on my watch again
500 000 new permanent jobs and a huge
number of construction jobs that
answered my question
i know i'm coming to it so what we say
is you cannot build the buildings that
we used to build that create a huge
amount of greenhouse gas emission
you need to be build buildings that are
clean there's a huge amount of work in
that
we need buildings to be retrofitted
we're going to train workers to do that
who's going to pay for jobs who's going
to pay for the retrofit building owners
when they get the retrofit
make the money back over time because
they don't spend as much on energy
do you know how much retrofitting could
cost a building in new york
sure millions and that's what we need
and you know what i think they're going
to do
because i always say that corporations
don't pay taxes they pass it on to
consumers
they're going to raise the rent unless
of course you confiscate the building
which you said you might do if they
raise rent
no no no wait we didn't say anything
like that they're going to raise the
rent
on people so the people are going to pay
for the retrofit are going to demand
a building owners build green stop the
greenhouse gas emissions they're killing
all of us
i know you care about your children your
grandchildren i care about my children
their grandchildren about everyone in
the city
so we cannot go on this way we need a
green new deal and one of the key things
is to make sure buildings don't emit
what they used to now that means a lot
of jobs for people to fix those
buildings reconfigure those buildings
okay
build them green and assuming i assume
and i know
it's going to cost more those building
owners doing very very well
can handle the upfront costs and they
make it back because you're right
say that as if these people have
unlimited resources
there are some people that i know that
own apartments that have lost money on
apartments there are people that i know
that own buildings that have lost
buildings but this is something which is
making the money back but here's the
option
if we don't do something right then this
earth is in great danger we're the city
how many years do we got left yes how
dangerous is it it's very dangerous
the u.n estimate is 12 years before we
deal with much deeper problems then what
the hell are we arguing for let's throw
a big party if it's only 12 years
without let's get to work
let's get to working with new deal gives
us that opportunity
if you are going to eliminate steel and
glass
and it's going to be tens of millions of
eliminated we say if you don't put the
retrofit
no put the retrofits in put the if you
want steel and glass
green billions more build it green okay
that means that everyone that rents
those rooms or rents those offices or
rents those apartments are going to pay
more
my question is do you have an
alternative do you want are there other
build
are there other materials are there
other materials that you can use besides
steel and glass
yeah they're certain tell me i'm not the
expert on building materials but there's
a lot of innovation here's some picks
and trees no we can't use trees
status quo is not working the earth is
more and more endangered
sandy you saw what sandy did hurricane
sandy in new york city
okay look at with 40 plus billion
dollars in damage
lives tons of lives lost we have to
change this is the way buildings are one
of the biggest emitters out there
we have to do something about this law
in new york city is the toughest
materials
what are the alternatives i will happily
get you a list of building materials
don't have the
point i'm making to you is if we do the
status quo we are endangering the future
of this city in this nation okay
so that means milli tens and hundreds of
millions of dollars in additional costs
to build a new building and retrofit an
old building hang on those costs will be
put on
the residents of new york so you want to
do nothing and say i want to do that
wait you're not giving me an answer what
do you want to do honestly how do you
want to stop i don't buy into this u.n
hysteria but that's the center you don't
think there's global warming
i think i think there is absolutely
issues we need to be good stewards
let me finish of our environment and by
being good stewards
but on the other hand we have to
understand something
the lifeblood of america's economy
wait wait wait you're not answering
follow me
here's what i'm telling you do you
believe we have a problem with the
lifeblood
follow me and you're going to get your
answer the lifeblood of every economy in
this world
is oil gas and coal
now in the new green deal in 10 years
it says it wants to eliminate all use of
oil gas and coal do you support that
i support us as quickly as possible not
answering again if you haven't even let
the
sentence finish first of all you didn't
answer so i'll start and then i'll give
you
you'll get your own i'll make a deal
when i'm running for president and you
get your own show you get to ask the
question well on my show i'll ask the
question
don't you guess you don't have an honest
opinion i have an honest opinion okay my
job is to turn over warming
i want to be president yes okay answer
my questions i will ask you again
oil and gas are the life we want to move
off fossil fuels we have to make sure
people understand how long would you ban
it as quickly as possible we have to
make sure
how many in those industries get jobs
new green deal says 10 years
get off fossil fuels how many years
let's get people
in those industries how many years in
the green as quickly as possible
okay solyndra didn't work out all the
green new deals of obama didn't work out
so wait a minute you're saying to me you
do not believe
in global warming i am saying to you
just the opposite i am saying to you we
should be good stewards of our
environment and
what do you want to do differently what
do you want to do differently i am
recognizing a truth that you fail to
recognize
that every economy in this world is run
on oil
gas and coal and if america gets off it
as the green new deal that you support
has in 10 years you will watch
the greatest depression in the quickest
period of time
and it will destroy americans germany
where they
import germany that has moved to
renewables so aggressive no they haven't
yes they have
they and they are merkel just signed a
seven
billion dollar deal to make russia rich
again the question is
and you know this isn't your show again
see what it says up there
hannity it doesn't say de blasio
i ask the question you want to be
president right i asked my question i
want to be really clear
we have to get off fossil fuels because
it's causing how many years
i wanted to be as fast as possible
because the bottom line 10 15.
here's the bottom line we can turn to
renewables we can create jobs with
renewables we can protect our children
and
what you're saying is you think we could
transfer our dependence on
oil gas and coal yes and transition to
renewables renewables okay now my
question is
what are the renewables and how much do
they cost okay
right now i look at the equation the
other way around the renewables are
wind power solar power hydro geothermal
we have a lot of room for wind power in
new york where we
put it in the middle of the hudson well
you can put in long island sound which
is what people are talking about we'll
put it near the kennedy compound
the bottom line is these are
technologies that are working all over
the world
and if we don't change quick we're in a
lot of danger i care about what's going
to happen to the future generations
and i don't like what i see these
weather events they're not mistakes sean
this stuff is flooding the wildfires
it's happening because of global warming
we can't go on this way
in the 70s you can look at time magazine
and it said
that the new ice age is coming then it
was in the 80s
the world is overheating then it's now
this
generality that is climate change which
fits every climate condition
even ocasio-cortez congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez's chief of
staff said oh
great deal had nothing to do with
climate change it's about an agenda
all right moments ago i pressed new york
city mayor bill de blasio on
his big government agenda and even had
him explain his support for meatless
mondays for students
take a look i want to go over two more
issues and then
you know you should go out and buy me a
drink and uh
by the way you're not going to like get
rid of can we put salt back on the
tables in new york
why didn't why did mayor bloomberg take
away salt shakers from the tables
i'm a big guy i'm a smart guy i'd like
to make that decision on my own
i don't drink big gulps but don't you
think people should have the choice if
they want to drink them to drink them
i actually believe in freedom but i
think there are some very
thank you i want you to know you don't
want big gulps no listen
but there are some very common sense
things we do no listen
you don't make it easy for a kid to
drink a huge amount of soda they want to
buy so
they can buy soda but they don't buy the
amount of soda that's going to keep
making them obese
this just doesn't make i ran the streets
my parents had no clue where i was
growing up in long island
on any given day and you know what i did
with the money i made i hung out in a
candy store
i ate crap i went to mcdonald's
you and i grew up probably somewhat
similar time okay we didn't have the
obesity problem we have today
i ate mcdonald's i eat pizza i mean did
you see the amount of kids dealing with
obesity back no
i did not well so something happened and
we got to address it well kids ate more
and more fast food more more soda it's
not good it's not healthy for the
country by the way you care about
national security i do
then you want a healthy country you do
not want to generate i work out like
robotics
i do mixed martial arts 90 minutes a day
right but you can't want another
kid you have every right to go to
brooklyn eight miles away to do your
stupid workout i'm
that was stupid i'm defending you all
right here so you tweeted one day about
me you said
here's actually pretty funny i laughed
when i saw it it's quality tweet all
right so you're
you're wanting meatless mondays in
school right
yeah okay you know how i know hashtag
meatless mondays is a good idea because
our students love it
and that's sean hannity hates it that
was pretty funny i like that
because i do hate it i don't want the
government telling me our students do
love it
okay are you willing to put money on
that oh yeah okay let's have a bet you
name the amount i make a lot more than
you do
so here's what i would say i'm going to
let's let every kid in
every new york school vote i say
mcdonald's monday
tacos
uh wendy's wednesdays hang on uh
i really you really are a threat to
society pizza turkey thursdays
and kfc fridays now yeah if we let go
a lot of parents listening to you right
now you're losing you're losing viewers
right now among parents
listen i don't need that every day i
wish i could i'll blow up like a balloon
and i won't be able to come on the set
here's my bet though
that's my menu that i'm going to offer
and the kids can vote on my menu and
they can vote on your menu
you name the price after every new york
city city student
votes i'll give whatever amount you want
to bet to your charity if you win
and you give that amount to my charity
viewers so the substantive
truth let's just actually get to this
no by doing this we are helping kids to
be healthier
look we got an obesity problem in our
country i don't have a problem with that
we have an i don't have a problem one
day
try this option the other days i got the
other options it's balance
it's balanced okay pizza you don't have
a problem with in school
i'm a believer in pizza i i eat
cauliflower pizza i'm afraid to admit it
with extra cheese i i just you know
that's like you know people that get my
age you just don't burn it off like you
used to
um i i don't even know thank you for
your confession
i don't need mcdonald's a lot um i want
kids to exercise more
right i want more athletics yep schools
aren't cutting it
it's got to be the parents when we were
coming up they did the president's
competition the athletics you threw the
football through the tire do you
remember all that
yeah of course see i think we got to
refocus kids on physical action i'll
help you with that
we gotta re-focus on my physical
activity we gotta have get them have a
healthier diet
there's a lot but it really emphasizes
but you know they would pick my diet
over yours
reaching kids young these kind of things
helps a lot
but you know they picked my diet over
yours so you want you want a bunch of
kids deciding the fate of their diet
i would listen to is that what you want
the answer to your question
is that i'm speaking as a parent i'm
speaking as a parent i'm speaking as a
parent